bori what exactly happened at your house  my cousin is the one that told me about  all the witchcraft stuff witchcraft  don't worry man Lori's ancestors were  good witches  I told you never to go up there you have  no business going there besides she  doesn't need to know that we're going  there to do witchcraft experiments with  our friends so this is it hey it doesn't  look that bad you made it  nothing too scary right off the bat not  the coven used these in their rituals  their stories about a cult sacrificing  babies of this place the way this house  was built had something to do with the  spirit world keeping spirits out we like  keeping woman  I found a Ouija board here we're gonna  play it tonight  but you have to get him out of there you  understand is there a spirit with us  tonight yes I already started playing  the game  [Applause]  they'll keep you playing the game until  everyone dies  it's fantastic  you